when working with my client I have two
16 year old clients and I have two 80
something year old clients and every
10-year Gap in between and every single
one of them I'm always asking them how
do you feel how hard was that last set
and are we doing more on the next I'm
always pushing for progression another
rep five more pounds heck two and a half
pounds I'm always looking for
progression that's how you get stronger
and that's how you build muscle and for
longevity strength training has more
bang for the buck than any other
exercise that you can do because your
muscles are your engines I mean that's
one of the things that older people
struggle with is bawling because most
people haven't been doing strength
training their adult life and on average
starting about 30 if you're not doing
strength training you lose about five
pounds of muscle mass every 10 years
your typical 80 year old has not been
lifting weights all their life and they
tend to be kind of small not from a body
fat standpoint but just from a muscle
standpoint well as those muscles go away
their ability to support and stabilize
their body goes away and so strength
training is just huge for your longevity
believe Nation I have a very special
guest with me coach Kelly he's in my
entrepreneur Mastermind program and
we're going to talk about health today
he is the health expert I'm hoping to
learn a few things as well we're
answering some of your questions and if
you have questions for us for future
episodes you can go to Evan
carmichael.biz and there'll be links to
be able to ask us questions Kelly before
we dive into the first question why
don't you tell our audience a little bit
about you thank you so much for this
morning I can't even believe we're doing
this I'm I'm to say that I'm excited is
just
an understatement but outside of
Devotion to Faith and family my passion
for Fitness has been the dominant in my
life since I was 15 years old and I just
turned 55 so that's 40 Years of doing
this this is a second career for me I
was in sales for most of my adult life
and a little over five years ago I made
the decision that it's time to pursue my
passion and that was the best decision
that I have ever made I received
blessings and Confirmation every day
from my environment from my clients and
beyond that I'm doing the right thing
and so in in finding you last fall my
goal in the very beginning or from the
very beginning was just to expand my
reach I've been writing a Blog since
2015 and one of my members said and or
clients he said you should consider a
podcast well I jump straight past
podcast into video so here we are and
that's that's why I I sought you out
because I want to magnify multiply my
message and and reach more people help
more people amazing well it's amazing
having you Movie Makers it's great
having you in the Mastermind let's get
to some audience questions so the first
one that came in is what is your health
routine so why don't you start and then
I'll I'll inject mine as well what is
your health routine Kelly Evan I'm going
to practice this with one statement in
the last certification that I went
through a little over a year ago it was
on sleep Stress Management and overall
recovery and I can tell you from all the
nutrition and or just consultations that
I do recovery is an element that a lot
of people do not consider and one of the
statements that they made at the very
beginning of that course is that
a workout program is only as good as
your body's ability to recover from it
and as soon as they said that I took a
step back and thought you know
everything that we do in life over the
course of a week it's only as beneficial
as your body's ability your body your
mind to recover from it and so in going
through that certification it changed my
mindset about how I structure my
training I used to train six days a week
I mean I would lift weights on average
five to six days a week I have cut that
back now out of seven days and it's
partially built around my work schedule
I only live four days a week I do one
day of what I call Active recovery but
it's it's a walk in the park compared to
my four primary days and that's that's
largely strength training and then on
day five and I say the the last two days
the week in the spirit of Evan
Carmichael I take a long walk I love
walking in my neighborhood neighborhood
in the early mornings I think I pray I
reflect as I think of things I have my
phone with me I have I use email as my
my notes list and I'll send myself to
Do's you know just things that pop in my
mind that I would never consider during
the hustle bustle you know pace of an
ordinary day but just to unplug from the
world and to get out in nature and just
let my mind and body rest it's amazing
some of the things that I've come up
with and so my overall weekly schedule
is four days of training kind of an
active recovery day and then two rest
days because taking a walk is not I mean
it's it's rest
I love it okay so uh that's good as you
were sharing yours like oh Kelly doesn't
judge mine let's see we'll see how uh
see how the expert thinks about my
routine I like the United recovery I
wasn't initially going to go there but
but uh it's definitely an important part
so
I would break it down to you know
Fitness working out uh diet nutrition
and then I like adding recovery or sleep
as um as a third component so for me in
terms of working out the first is three
hours outside every day that's been a
new addition to my life it's been an
amazing new addition to my life uh I try
to work in chunks of 10 a.m to noon is
focused work uh we're filming this
actually here at 10 A.M Eastern my time
so this is part of my focus work block
obviously I'm inside and then 12 to 3 is
outdoor and I'm in Canada Toronto Canada
so uh it's that's the hottest point you
know we don't get like super crazy hide
so I want to get vitamin D we don't get
as much here in Toronto as other places
so 12-3 is outside and I try to do work
this is a big adjustment for me is how
do I do work when I'm outside because I
don't just have three hours to go on
walks every day so I do all all of my
phone work and and I've been especially
happy with voice to text so I'll speak a
lot of things because typing on the
phone is just too slow compared to doing
it here in my office and so I'll do my
DMs I'll do my text messages I'll do my
social media I'll do uh calls with
people anything that I can do I'll do
all my emails when I'm walking and it's
all just me talking into my phone and
that's been a huge game changer for me
I'm used to standing up so I'm on a
trampoline right now I mean I'm I'm
bouncing on my trampoline uh that was a
big game changer for me earlier on in my
career but getting outside getting
Sunshine getting the activity is is
pretty low impact right it's just
walking I'm not coming back with like my
heart beating I'm not sweating like
crazy but it's it's shocking how just
walking every day can have a big impact
on how you feel uh on your health
Etc so I think most people just aren't
getting the Bare Basics of of activity
in you don't have to go and prepare to
do a triathlon or something like just
walk every day it doesn't even have
doesn't be three hours that may be a
little extreme but like 20 minutes of
walking every day can change your life
so start with that right then in terms
of uh Fitness
I will go to the gym four times a week
so I like that we're we're uh we're the
same there
for you and we'll do two types of
workouts so like Monday and Thursday
will be one workout and Tuesday and
Friday will be a different workout and
then Wednesday and Sunday will be a run
the run is however long I feel like
going so it's a couple times around a
very big block
um and as I you know get better I I get
more endurance and just keep going
um and so ultimately that becomes six
days a week uh now there's exceptions I
travel sometimes and I'm not in the gym
Etc but I'd say I hit that 85 percent of
the time I don't think anybody's 100
always on their routine but 85 percent
of the time that's basically what I'm
doing so four times in the gym two times
running every day will be uh 25 minute
sauna when I'm home followed by a cold
plunge or a cold shower you can keep
that you can keep that the cold shower
the sauna or both no the cold part I
don't do cold
it takes a while to get used to
um but I find especially if you come out
of something really hot so do I'll do
hot sauna into hot shower and then I'm
so hot it's like oh my gosh I just need
to cool down and then get into the cold
is actually a relief
um that's a lot easier than just going
straight cold at least for me
and I'm in Canada so like we're used to
cold but I just believe in the uh the
science around cold plunging as well as
sauna I think from a health and fitness
that's that's mostly what I do and then
when I'm home I'm on my trampoline
um we try to do walks my wife and I
after dinner so after dinner there'll be
our biggest meal of the day and then
we'll go for a 20 minute walk with the
dog from the park just to lower the uh
blood glucose after our big meal and
that's basically what I do Fitness wise
for nutrition I have one uh usually a
breakfast when I wake up uh and then
I mostly don't eat lunch unless
something happened and I'm I'm really
hungry for whatever reason it's
typically if I lack protein so if I
don't eat 100 grams of protein in the
morning then I'll get hungry throughout
the day if I eat like this morning I had
turkey
uh and some cauliflower rice and I am
full you know like 100 grams of protein
from turkey and I'm like I'm I'm good
and so I have one day that's
um a fat day and then one day that is a
light carb day and carb is not like uh
bread and pasta but more fruits so
the fat day would be you know red meat
eggs Etc but really low on the carbs uh
but you know cooking oil and that kind
of stuff but not the crazy seed oil and
then the the carb they would be low fat
still protein so turkey that's today
chicken Etc and then fruits for the day
and just basically trying to train my
body to be uh flexible between burning
fat and burning
carbs right now I'm not doing any sugar
any pasta any breads any any packaged
Foods right like Doritos or any you know
any of that other stuff and that's my
training right now on the nutrition side
and then recovery
just trying to keep to a routine
as much as possible
I try to be in bed by 11.
I'll start getting ready for bed at 10.
I'll be in bed by 11. and I wake up when
I wake up so no alarm
the first thing that I do
the first median of any of any day is 10
o'clock so technically my day doesn't
start till 10 o'clock so this is the
first thing that I'm doing that we
started this at 10 o'clock Eastern today
but I woke up at six something today we
started dming already you were up for a
couple hours already excited for this I
got up at six something but I don't set
an alarm I haven't set an alarm for
I mean years unless I have a morning
flight that's typically the only thing I
try not to speak first thing in the
morning if I'm doing an event I try not
to travel first thing in the morning if
I can avoid it at all costs and I try
not to commit myself because if I knew
similar to you if I if I knew something
was happening in the morning I wouldn't
sleep because I'd be I'd be stressed out
that what if I don't wake up on time
even though I set the alarm like what if
the alarm doesn't go off and then I have
just the worst night's sleep
so I try to plan nothing before 10 a.m
as much as possible and then I wake up
whenever I wake up and I never wake up
at 10 like that's you know if I'm going
to bed I'm in bed by 11 uh I'm never
waking up past what's the latest I mean
usually eight as the latest but I'm I
think I'm typically up 637 but if my
body needs extra rest my body needs
extra rest so there you go I think if
we're taking people through my workout
routine my food regiment right now and
then rest and Recovery what what do you
think Kelly coach Kelly is it coach
Kelly approved am I an idiot from where
what do you got for me I was actually
surprised how you how early you were up
this morning I was just warming up at
the gym when I got your first message
but
Evan my my one question is how is your
body responding to what you're doing
everything that you just shared with me
sounds really good what are you trying
to accomplish and is your body
responding favorably towards that so I
think I'm trying to accomplish different
things with the rest it's it's just
trying to be alert the next day
one day of no sleep or poor sleep I can
manage it's when it hits two to three
days in a row that I would I start to
really feel the effects and that usually
happens if I'm in a conference or an
event and I need to be saved by myself
like from myself so
um I'll either have Nina my wife with me
or team who like Evan you need to go to
bed it's two o'clock and you're still in
the lobby talking to entrepreneurs
because I get lost I'll just I'll just
help and serve and then not realize that
it's 2 A.M and I haven't eaten or gone
in the bathroom and I'm running a fever
so the rest recovery is super important
uh for me so it's just how do I feel the
next day for the diet nutrition it's
it's a combination of
um
weight management I don't need to lose a
ton of weight I'm not like massively
overweight or something
um and then also just longevity I just
right believe in the science of hey if I
do these things I will live longer and
and I want to live longer to
go after my mission it's a lot harder to
feel some of these things on a
day-to-day basis you know does having a
sauna give me extra energy the next day
I no like I can't say that it doesn't
take away energy but I can't say it's
adding energy does going to the gym and
working uh on My zotman Curls you know
uh have a huge impact the next day no I
mean I feel it my muscles are sore but
it's hard for me to gain a ton of weight
and I'm also slow to put on muscles so I
don't see big gains and I don't feel any
different really I'm also coming in at a
pretty high level I think uh in that I'm
not eating processed food I'm not having
sugar all the time and so I'm going for
the final stages of optimization as
opposed to like how do I get started and
doing a lot of the basics for you to be
doing strength training four days a week
is awesome I mean that's just like gold
you get a gold star for that you really
don't need gold star from coach Kelly
let's go
you really don't need more than that but
when working with my clients I mean
whether I have two 16 year old clients
but I have two 80 something year old
clients and every 10-year Gap in between
and every single one of them I'm always
asking them how do you feel how hard was
that last set and are we doing more on
the next I'm always pushing for
progression another rep five more pounds
heck two and a half pounds I'm always
looking for progression and again it's
with all of my clients because there's
there's always room to to do more and
that's that's how you get stronger and
that's how you build muscle and
for longevity strength training has more
bang for the buck than any other
exercise that you can do because your
muscles are your engines I mean that's
one of the things that older people
struggle with is well one of the dangers
of getting older risk factors is falling
because most people haven't been doing
strength training their adult life and
on average starting about 30
if you're not doing strength training
you lose about five pounds of muscle
mass every 10 years see them they're
going from 30 to 80 your typical 80 year
old has not been lifting weights all
their life and they tend to be kind of
small not from a body fat standpoint but
just from a muscle standpoint well as
those muscles go away their ability to
support and stabilize their body goes
away and so strength training is just
huge for your for your longevity I mean
I applaud you for what you're doing I
think ultimately as I get older I mean
I'm 43 right now so I'm not super
worried about this yet but flexibility
then also becomes a thing as well you
talk about Falls it's the strength
training to make sure that you hopefully
don't fall in the first place because
your muscles are are strong but then if
you do follow the the flexibility so
that the risk of injury is a lot lower
that something's not breaking it's
bending because you've been doing the
flexibility training so I'm sure at some
point that's on my radar uh it's not an
immediate priority but uh it's something
on the radar as I as I continue to age
Evan consider this and it's very much to
use it or lose it philosophy you do
strength training for the obvious you do
cards and that's not to say that you can
get a very strong cardio effect from
from a properly planned strength
training workout but you do strength
training for first strength you do
cardio for cardio Mobility work you can
be the strongest dude in the world
but that doesn't mean there's got to be
mobile you have to specifically work on
Mobility Mobility flexibility the words
are semantics but you have to work on
that but then there's tissue work as
well and if you can't afford a massage
therapist on a regular basis there's all
type foam rollers and different
modalities that you can use the quality
of your muscle tissue that is a separate
area of emphasis I mean that's why
massage therapists are in business I
mean there's there's something to be
said for maintaining your muscle tissue
quality it helps you with your overall
movement better you know for the long
term so
get getting into the fascia yes sir yes
sir absolutely let's get to our next
question so the next question coming in
was how do you bounce back after Health
complications slow you down so I'll tell
you a quick story
um
in September of 14
I tore my left bicep to my horror I was
doing dumbbell curls you know seeing
myself in the mirror and that left arm
ripped and I had just started a new job
and I did not have I was three weeks in
didn't have the insurance I rolled the
dice I didn't pay for cobra
and I was screwed because I didn't have
the money to pay for surgery and so I
rehabbed the best that I could and once
my insurance kicked in say three months
later I went to a sports medicine Doc
and he said 50 50 odds that I could even
find the loose end of your bicep to
reattach it he said if it were me based
on how well you've recovered without I'd
just not get it fixed that's the worst
advice ever I wish I would have at least
given it a shot because my left arm to
this day
your God gave us a bicep for a reason
it's two muscles there not just one but
fast forward to 2016 I had the same kind
of pain in my shoulder that I had in the
left before that bicep tore
I learned my lesson so I went to the
doctor
um
did MRI he said you have four tears in
your rotator cuff but your bicep tendon
is fraying like a rope and they said you
don't let me fix it it's going to do
what you're left arm did so we did
rotator cuff surgery and then bicep
reattachment that was in March of 16.
that was on a Friday
I had to wait till my parents went home
before I could do this but the next
Friday I was back in the gym now my arm
was in a sling I could not use my rod
arm for 14 weeks of physical therapy but
my left arm and my legs work just fine
and I never missed a workout I worked
around that injury I was in PT for 14
weeks doctor finally released me from PT
and it was just a Mobility thing I had
to reach certain Mobility standards with
that right arm and at that point he
released me to start lifting essentially
pink dumbbells I mean I could lift just
I had no strength in my right arm it
took me another 14 months to get back to
full strength but Evan I never skipped a
beat I worked in there was a number of
rehab exercises that my therapist taught
me in PT that she encouraged me to
continue and is all about Mobility so I
worked those in my rotation as I'm
working the rest of my body but I mean
for months I was just doing all my upper
body I felt like an idiot at first but I
thought this is better than nothing the
bottom line answer is it has to do with
mindset I made the decision a month
before surgery that I was not going to
let it be any more impactful than
possible I knew that my left arm was
still going to work that my legs would
be fine there was no reason to change my
nutrition and I didn't
and it ended up being I mean I wrote I
wrote several blogs on it and I I just I
claimed before I ever did the surgery
that I was going to be a blessing to
other people by the example that I set I
claimed it and then it happened in the
gym I would have different people come
up to me over that period of time as I
was recovering and basically just
applaud me on my efforts and I I just I
felt good about the example that I was
setting so overcoming an injury it's all
mindset it is all mindset you can choose
to make the most of it or you can choose
to Let It Whip you and I just refuse to
let it with me yeah I love it that's a
great story man and I mean I resonate in
2019 I broke my neck I was on tour doing
90 days 23 cities Across America and in
Denver I broke my neck I fainted hit my
head on the wall I had a just giant cut
on my forehead and then concussion from
that and then broke my neck in two spots
because I slid down and my neck hit the
baseboard and just crack my neck in two
spots uh never really had a broken bone
in my life never had a concussion at all
and then all of a sudden rushed to the
ER and had to wear a neck brace for 60
days and he said 50 chance that I had to
have spinal surgery uh which is scary
when you're talking spinal surgery loss
can go wrong so like okay well I'm gonna
be in that 50 that doesn't need it right
it's like mindset right away I'm gonna
be in that 50 and I wore neck brace for
60 days and I continued on my tour so
the default was okay well I guess you're
going to cancel the tour my agent's like
okay go home to Toronto rest like well I
mean I might have to cancel my tour but
why not just try one city at a time and
see what happens because for me I felt
like the healing would come by being
around entrepreneurs and doing the work
that I love as opposed to me just being
at home lying at a couch I told my my
doctor uh we canceled that night in
Denver because that was supposed to be
my speaking okay and I said well if I
get out of here tomorrow can I just have
people come over to my Airbnb because we
had this house uh and I'll just lie on
the couch and just help people and they
can come into the Airbnb and like
whatever keep going and the doctor's
like uh no you can't do that
you have a concussion like you gotta
rest your brain a little bit uh that's
not good the concussion was worse than
the the neck uh pain I mean the pain was
strong but I could deal with physical
pain it was the mental fogginess not
able to think not able to look at a
screen not even look at lights that
really messed me up and thankfully the
concussion didn't last as long as the
the you know the neck injury but I think
the key to bouncing back is just
recognizing that you you need to do the
best of what you've got
that you're not where you were yesterday
right like me I was not where I was the
day before because now I broke my neck
and I just did the best that I could
with what I had and so some of that was
really tough you know I remember leaving
the hotel uh leaving the hospital
and we had this giant Suburban at the
time
um for the trip and I couldn't get into
the Suburban so one I couldn't drive
obviously now right my neck is broken I
can't move my neck at all so I'm not
driving so now my Nina my little wife is
driving to Suburban and we're checking
out of the hospital and I'm trying to
get into the passenger side of of the
car and I can't get in I get one foot in
and then it hurts my whole spine is just
on fire and I can't get into the car but
I also can't get out of the car any
movement now was just massive pain
and I started to cry like in the parking
lot of this hospital because I'm in so
much pain and also so frustrated that I
don't know what to do I can't go forward
I can't go back I'm just stuck here
uh and then eventually Nina just
pushed me in we we made it like oh my
gosh and I got into the car and then
that night I needed to go to the
bathroom at three in the morning and the
nurse had taught me at the hospital how
to how to get myself up from a lying
position to a seated position so it
wouldn't hurt my my body too much and I
could get I got up three in the morning
I'm sitting on the edge of my bed it's
pure dark in our in our Airbnb and
I feel like I'm getting a little dizzy
and
I don't want to wake up my wife to go to
the bathroom it feels like it's the most
helpless thing like waking up her she's
had a rough day rough week and now I
need help to take me to the bathroom you
know all the things like I can't go just
go to the bathroom by myself
and but then I didn't want to get up and
faint again and fall over and then I
rushed back to the hospital so I I woke
her up and she helped me go to the
bathroom one then I went back to bed
it's just recognizing that you're doing
the best you can with what you got
and so it continued on the tour I sat at
the front with ice packs and pillows and
I wasn't as good on stage as I was at
the beginning of my tour where I was
walking around but people said they even
liked it better to your point of view
going to the gym and inspire people
people saw me sitting at the front of an
event talking for four hours with a
broken neck and they're like What's My
excuse for not chasing them my goals
again wait what uh I just had a rough
night or something right and so people
saw that it wasn't really my intention
but people saw that as an inspiration
and so it's being a little more gentle
on yourself to recognize that
you had a real issue and and that could
be a physical uh issue that could be a
mental issue could be a family issue
um but it's a real issue and the key
thing is just to not stop the momentum
you know you still went back to the gym
and you were not doing what you were
doing the day before and you're lifting
pink weights you know like but lifting a
two pound weight when you're used to 50
or whatever you know the exchanges uh
feels like it's a giant step back and
this is where people stop because
they're not where they used to be and so
they want to quit but but like a two
pound weight might even be heavier for
you than the 50 pound was the day before
because of how much your muscles are now
kind of getting used to each other again
and so it's just rewarding yourself for
taking the best effort as opposed to
just looking at the results of what
you're doing
um and so chances are whoever your
heroes are you know they've had a lot of
setbacks too and the thing that set them
apart was they just kept going they
found their way to keep going and so you
do the best you can with what you got to
keep the momentum happening amen next
question let's move on okay how to
improve your mental health ooh what do
you got for that one Kelly
Evan there's so many different
directions that you can go that is such
a broad topic so I'm just gonna boil it
down to one thing
the world's message is largely negative
and it will be a path to your door every
single day via social media be a news
via just is just that's just the way it
is
first of all I think that you have to
fortify and protect yourself from the
negative message that you're going to be
bombarded with every day I don't watch
the news the first thing that I do in
the morning is wake up turn on the
coffee maker turn on my computer and I
start the day in Bible study I don't see
what's happening in the world until I
get to the gym we have TVs across the
front part of the gym and I will glance
at as I'm walking by and there's a
couple of new station Stations and also
always been the philosophy that if it's
bad enough I'm going to hear about it
but I mean just the general news about
who just shot who I don't need to know
that
that doesn't make me a better son
coach to my client brother friend any of
the roles that I play in my life
negative news does not make me do any
better in those roles but so there's the
fortify side and then there's the
putting in the positive and I love the
great late Zig Ziglar he said
it's kind of like taking a bath
you take a bath every day because if you
don't you're going to stink the weight
and weight of Zig he said it's the same
thing with your attitude and your
mindset you have to work on that every
single day it wears off it is a daily
discipline Evan I listen to a largely
audio but he might read as well but on a
daily basis I spent on average two to
three hours of putting positive content
in my head in my head in my head and
it's a daily deal and I've been doing
that for years and years and years and
years and years and all I can say is it
makes a difference I mean it makes a
difference you have to fortify and
protect and then you have to put in the
good and that little cycle I've been
doing for a lot of years and it's made
all the difference in the world to me
yeah I'm I'm right there with you Kelly
I think the environment really really
really matters and so if you're in a
really negative environment you got
people telling you can't do things you
got family members friends uh people at
school people at work I understand most
people hate their lives most people are
not out living their best life and so
it's not even that they're negative or
toxic people I don't I don't think
people I don't believe in haters or
people are bad they're just people who
are in a lot of pain and when you're in
a lot of pain you do you do stupid
things like when when you and I were in
pain we might have been rude to somebody
it doesn't mean you're a bad person
you're just deal with a lot of pain and
if you look at most people they're
dealing with a lot of pain in their
lives and so you would you'd expect
somebody in pain to lash out
and so if you're around all these people
all the time though that starts to seep
into you uh and so I love the idea of of
protect
um my version of that is hey like just
sub out the one like who's the most
negative person in your life or news
source or media Source or whatever and
just sub that person out or limit access
because maybe that's your mom and you
don't want to sub her out of your life
but but limit access or limit some of
the things that you talk about and then
Sub in positivity
and maybe that's a human that you
actually know like think about who of
your friends or people in your circle
makes you feel better after you leave
right like a lot of times we hang out
with people then we feel drained
afterwards
well like stop hanging around with
people who make you feel drained after
this session I'm gonna I have more
energy leaving today than coming in
because of Kelly like it's the one plus
one equals 14 of us being together
instead of one plus one being equals a
two or or zero because it's drained us
right I'm gonna have more energy leaving
than coming in and so when you find
those people
try to spend more time with them try to
you take the initiative of asking them
to go for coffee because it may be
somebody who is not a close friend yet
but it's just in your circle somebody
you've met at an event or you met at
school or you met at work it just find a
way to spend more time with them because
if you sub out one negative person and
Sub in one positive person so many
things can change and then I would
supplement that with content which is
why I do what I do with all the videos
that I make every day it's like this
there's the new video every single day
on multiple channels that will inject
positivity and hope and belief and
optimism into your brain and I need it I
still need it for myself it's I mean
Kelly is looking at two hours a day of
of learning I need it myself too I need
I want Oprah in my ear every day and
Steve Jobs every year every day and Elon
Musk my ear every day and people have
done amazing things so that makes me
want to play a bigger game as well and
so people say that social media is
negative and toxic
um not for me
you're like you get the control my my
YouTube is beautiful my Instagram is
awesome I go there I'm seeing I'm seeing
a new video from Kelly coming out it's
great like you get to control it
so stop looking at the negative stuff
unfollow the people who make you feel
worse about yourself that that Doom
scrolling unfollow all those people stop
interacting with their content and sub
in the people who make you feel inspired
and hopeful and motivated because if you
are around those people both in your
life and virtually consistently
that's going to change your life they
will naturally just pull you up if
you're around Kelly every day you're
gonna have a growth mindset you're going
to start working out more you're gonna
it might start with just a walk around
the block every day but if you're
looking at his content every day you're
gonna start picking up new habits if you
if you watch a Zig Ziglar every day The
Legend You're gonna start dreaming
bigger you're going to start believing
yourself more you're going to start
having more action taken and less
thinking about doing things because
you've engineered that person into your
life and so you don't even have to know
them that's the power of the internet
like Zig Ziglar will has passed but
Ziggler's past Kelly may not come and
hang out with you every day but you can
hang out with his content every day and
I can make a dramatic shift forward so
sub out one person who's negative
subbing one person's positive and then
carefully curate the people you follow
to make sure that they're making you a
better version of you what habits do you
do every single day without fail that
makes the biggest difference for you who
what do you got Kelly
this is in the spirit of Zig
and it's also to honor my grandfather
and my pastor
kazig would be disappointed if I didn't
say what I'm about to say and uh so my
mom told me one time that my grandfather
and he passed away back in 03 he was a
Baptist preacher when I was just a baby
so I had no recollection of that but she
told me that this just a few years ago
she said
you know your grandfather used to say
that 90 with God
is better than 100 on your own
and I just like okay I mean I knew what
she was talking about
and then son of a gun my pastor for the
last 20 years I go to Prestonwood
Baptist Church in Plano Dr Jack Graham
and he's been there for over 25 years
now he said the exact same thing from
Pulpit a couple of years ago I thought
my Two Jacks but
how that statement resonates with me is
very simple and it it's it's makes all
the difference in my life so nine
percent with God instead of 100 on your
own the first day of the week for me is
Sunday I honor God by giving my time by
going to church
Fridays are when I get paid and so every
I love Friday mornings I get up coffee
computer
before I jump into my Bible study
because it's kind of part of it I see
what my check is from Lifetime and I
give based on my personal commitment and
then I move I do my investing I move
some money into I have a couple of IRAs
and then whatever my current credit card
bill is I paid every week I never pay
interest on my credit card and that's
just that that's my little Friday deal
but I still honoring God with giving him
that part that I've committed to and
then on Evan on a day-to-day basis
I give God the first part of every day
it's coffee and bible study carved in
stone no exceptions whatsoever even when
I had that shoulder surgery I can go
back and show you in my journal because
that first weekend my arm was in this
big honking cast I couldn't use my hand
or anything I did my Bible study Journal
notes with my left hand now it was
uglish
but I did it I mean I I did not keep
that from doing my Bible study in the
morning and so that for me my faith is
the foundation I guess Fitness and
personal development is second but faith
is first and foremost the foundation of
my life and um I'll never change I mean
it's it's me let me say this one thing
one of my best clients actually I just
trained him this morning he was before
this session with you he and I were
talking finances one day and it came up
about investing and so forth and I
mentioned that you know that I tithe
every week and he said
you mean you give that much money to
your church and I said yes he said
imagine how much you would have if you
didn't do that now he's one of my very
best clients he's a dear dear friend
and so I said it very respectfully but I
counter back I said Omar I see it
completely opposite I see all that I
have all the blessings that I've
received as a result of being faithful
with you know my ties and that that was
a perspective shifter for him um for me
to put it that way but anyway that is
the Habit I've been doing that morning
that whole those three things now since
probably the early 2000s consistently
and that's something that I'll do for
you know indefinitely I see this
question I can answer it in two ways
either you know the spirit of the
question or the actual question because
it says every single day without fail
and I don't know that I've done
anything every single day with intention
with without fail
um I mean the to the spirit of the
question I think I do the most
consistently would be injecting optimism
into my life whether it's a video
whether it's a book whether it's
um something that I you know I I'm
reading on the airplane or uh a film
that I'm watching a documentary
injecting positivity is probably
consistently over the past 20 years the
most consistent thing that I've done now
I'm very disciplined and I have a lot of
habits
and most of my habits I'm hitting 85 to
95 of the time
the health you know routine that we
talked about earlier you know but if I'm
traveling from here to Japan uh I'm
probably not hitting my sauna for the
day you know they're like just some
things that are not practical or as more
detrimental to do it than not to do it
in some cases like it's better to go and
sleep than to go and do that thing or
it's better to serve because this is a
big opportunity than to go do that thing
so when it says you know
do this daily without fail I think the
most consistent thing is just injecting
optimism into my life and I'm okay with
hitting 85 to 95 percent consistency on
on my habits as long as you're proud for
me as long as I'm proud of the reason
why I'm not doing it
right so even making videos the only
time in the past
decade plus that I have not made videos
I made videos when I broke my neck
I made videos when I went on tour I made
videos through everything the only time
I did not make videos is when my dog
died my dog passed away on on uh video
day and I was just this family dog for
you know 13 14 years and I just I was
destroyed and I could not make videos
and I could have forced myself and like
made videos and cried through everything
it just I felt like I needed to honor
Toby and uh and so that's what I that's
what I did thankfully both my parents
are still alive but if they have a major
health issue or something else happens
in my family
uh I might be a total wreck I don't know
like I I may not if if my mom dies at
some point uh maybe I don't make videos
for a week or a month I don't know you
know maybe I don't even consume any
optimistic content I have no idea how
I'm gonna react it's going to destroy my
world
um and I'm okay with that you know it's
like it's you are where you consistently
do not necessarily what you do every
single every single day But to answer
the question of what what's the habit I
do every single day without fail if I
had to pick one besides the optimism
it's probably check in with Nina
I don't know that there's been a day in
the past decade that I have not
checked in with Nina
obviously I mean we live together so you
know we're married Etc so that's easy on
the daily but but when I'm traveling
I don't think I've ever done a day
without at least saying Hi how are you I
love you thinking of you like even a
quick text or message
and that's how it should be
well I you know I wouldn't I also
wouldn't judge myself if I didn't if I
was like no I no access to Internet I'm
in the middle of a jungle or something
and I can't get on internet
it's not it's not the end of the world
right it's like oh my gosh my identity
is destroyed now that I that I missed
but I think of of you know priorities
um that quick even 18 second check-in
um is hopefully meaningful for her
because it's meaningful for me
just don't want to know what I'm
thinking about here I think I've
probably done that every single day
without fail for the past decade Plus
so there you go final answer I was just
gonna say on I meant to include the
second part of that morning Bible study
it is absolutely switch over to positive
input positive mindset and you've been
pretty much top of the playlist now
since last fall
well seriously just because of the
content I mean I'd never heard of Tom
belyou
um I knew kind of about Grant Cardone
but but just you introduced me to a lot
of new people that I've never heard
before and it's been just it's it's
awesome and now I've got I've got a file
of your stuff saved that just goes
forever and ever and ever so there's
there's lots of content to dig into on a
daily basis you'll you'll probably run
out of hours before I run out of content
there's there's a lot to go through over
the past 14 years of making videos yes
there is well Evan thank you so much
this has been amazing thank you for the
awesome answers Kelly thank you for
being a part of the The Mastermind the
movie makers for people watching if they
want to learn more about you connect
with you where's the best place for them
to go I work at Lifetime Fitness North
Dallas the easiest way is my email is
kellyamadon gmail.com
um to reach out and or Evan can I give
my cell number if you want people
calling you well that would mean a call
or a text I mean I'm open uh
469-499-6986 I'm here to serve the world
and I have the capability here of doing
that so I'm open and you do you know
coaching and nutrition and and training
and you can you can serve anybody with
the information and knowledge you've got
I do I do personal training I do
nutrition coaching I do I help people
with their sleep I can work with people
obviously in our gym but I can we have
the capabilities I can work with anyone
across the country we have the we have
the ability to do that so I can serve
anywhere as long as there's an internet
connection where we can connect I love
it well thank you for being you Kelly
and sharing your wisdom here today thank
you Evan I look forward to speaking with
you again soon much love to see my last
Mastermind q a with mindset Mary check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there get an idea and go do
something about it like expect it to
expect it to have a million mistakes
don't judge yourself for how well you
know the thing does but just you just
start because you came up with the idea
and so trust in your ideas